hi everyone
welcome to our session on building a
petabyte scale reporting pipeline on gcp
i'm minhas kazi a developer advocate at
google and i'll be joined by michael
wallman
michael is an infrastructure lead at
google cloud platform
in this presentation we'll be talking
about how gcp and waze collaborated to
implement a solution for
a petabyte scale reporting platform
we'll also show how this project aligns
with the vision for our analytics uh
program the database management
analytics vision is on the slide and as
you can see
we we focus a lot on an open philosophy
we want to deliver flexible features and
apply intelligent google technologies to
help our customers
throughout the presentation we'll be
talking about business requirements and
challenges
let's project add and then we'll also
talk about the technical architectures
and data pipelines
finally we'll talk about the connector
we created and then the
dashboard solution we came up with and
the outcomes
but first here's tommy han from waze
we'll be talking about the business
requirements and challenges
thank you my name is tommy hunt and i'm
an analyst at waze
many of you may be familiar with waze is
a crowdsource navigation app
that helps get you from place to place
we have over 130 million monthly active
users
across 185 countries that collectively
completed
over 1 billion navigations in 2019
our partners and users reported over 60
million traffic incidents each month
and our map is maintained by 30 000
volunteer map editors
best of all waze is completely free for
anybody to use
under the hood waze is even bigger than
that we're a mobility platform that
helps people move more freely in the
communities where they live and work
just as we give users access to
real-time information within the app
we also partnered with over 1300 cities
towns and non-profit organizations
to share that data through a program we
call ways for cities
helping to inform their mobility
strategies and their responses
in fact we currently help with more than
60 crises each year such as hurricanes
and earthquakes
and we're helping cities get safer
through beacons by giving drivers a way
to stay connected even when they're out
of range of gps
in our newest initiative waze carpool is
helping to combat
the rising congestion in cities around
the world
our city partnerships and community
driven approach is what makes waze
unique
and sets us apart from other navigation
apps if you're interested in learning
more about waze or if you're interested
in becoming a ways for cities partner
visit waze.com ways for cities
now through our waste for cities program
we offer a variety of tools and
offerings which include
data sharing carpool beacons and crisis
mitigation
today we're going to focus on how google
cloud has helped us
improve one of these offerings the data
that we share with partners
through our data sharing offering waze
provides real-time proprietary incident
and slow down information generally
generated by millions of ways drivers to
inform our partners mobility strategies
the data we share includes user
generated reports like traffic jams
crashes constructions and potholes just
to name a few
now before we begin working with google
cloud waze data was shared with our city
partners via a geo rss feed
in json and xml formats partners had to
take a lot of steps to begin using this
data
these steps included ingesting storing
and then paying for the ongoing storage
of this waze data
among several other technical details
needless to say it was really difficult
for many of our resource straps city
partners to consider this process
which really limited most of our
partners ability to use our data at all
so that's why we turn to google cloud to
find a way to manage and share this data
with our partners in a simpler and
overall more cost effective way
now i'll turn it over to my colleague
michael to talk about the technical
implementation of this tool
okay hi so starting with the
waze and uh google cloud platform
integration so obviously bigquery
we started with bigquery and in
combination with data studio
was the um platform or the services of
choice
okay challenges so um
first we need to ingest data from an
outside source
so waze provided us an api to hit and we
we use that api to pull in data all the
world's traffic data
another challenge is that uh we the
system had to support
thousands of partners at once so there's
no telling when partners were using the
system or making queries
so therefore we had to assume that there
would be a lot of concurrency in the
thousands
um simply user-aware dashboards
meaning that if i'm a partner and i go
to go to a dashboard
i would like to see the data that's
relevant to me whereas
another partner should see the data
that's relevant to them without moving
around
um or having to to set that on every
login
so that was really important another
challenge would be if i were to make
changes to the default dashboards
they should they should propagate for
all partners so i didn't want to have to
uh edit or have individual dashboards
per partner
it was a request or does not pay model
meaning that
partners are not charged for this
service and that that
google or waze in this case is is
providing the service for free
and then one of the major challenges
which wasn't technical is that it was a
small development team with little to no
sre support
okay before i go into details on the
technical architecture i want to call
out a teammate
igan sores from our laptop customer
engineering team
who really helped design and develop
these pipelines
i myself worked with egon but also
mainly focused on the
connector and the dashboard development
so uh number one we had our data
pipelines
so we ingested the world's um traffic
data
in essence into bigquery uh number two
user management
partners on board into the system
through a simple web portal
and then number three they go to a
default dashboard
they get access to the data that's of
interest to them and number four is
like how to use the partner's behavior
how the partners are actually accessing
the data to make judgments on
what data is valuable to our partners
and what dashboards are they
are they really finding value in so we
can modify the dashboards
accordingly okay the data pipeline
we used app engine flex and its chrome
functionality
to stream data in from waze's
traffic api into bigquery partition
tables
and so cron would run periodically and
we would basically
query the api and pull in all the data
for that period since the last
run and write it into partition tables
and then
from these partition tables we would set
up we set up bigquery schedule
jobs and so what they would do is they
would transform and dedupe the data
writing into writing into cluster tables
in bigquery
okay user management the u
the user management consisted of
partners
um logging into a web portal
and and selecting the polygons they're
interested in
and and this gets written into a partner
table in bigquery we chose to use
bigquery because
just for simplicity it's not i mean this
is a very small table so it doesn't
really fit the bigquery use case
but uh for simplicity we just decided to
keep the user information
in bigquery as well so uh similar
following a similar pattern as the data
pipelines we have an
app engine job that runs in that uses
cron to run periodically
it looks at the partner table and based
on changes whether a partner gets added
or removed
it creates spec it creates authorized
views
for these partners in bigquery now you
see
uh as you see from the diagram there's
there's something called
intermediate views and we had to add
these because of a
uh to work around the 2500
uh limit of authorized views per data
set so
in essence it's a we have created views
of views
and and intermediate views basically use
an ascii regex to dock root partners in
in different intermediate views and this
allowed us to get over that 2500 limit
and now minhas is going to cover the
reporting requirements
thank you michael stepping from the
technical challenges we had
uh we determined what the recur
requirements for the reporting would be
first was that the data for separate
cities were in separate data sets
they would have to be accessed from
separate data sets and there we'd have
to ensure
data privacy because uh we didn't want
any of the partners to see
other partners data so if they were
looking at a dashboard or any kind of
reporting solution
they would only be able to see their own
cities data and not anyone else's one
there is also a requirement for the
centralized billing to have that
frictionless user experience
because since we didn't want the
city's partners to carry the bill for
this dashboard
the billing would be meant managed
centrally by the
ways and gcp teams so there will be a
central billing account that will be
taking care of the bigquery querying
through the dashboard
there also have to be a single point of
change for all the dashboard edits
uh that means if a future change was
made to the dashboard or if any kind of
update was to be made
it would have to get rolled out to all
the partners at the same time
so there have to be some kind of a easy
deployment system for that
and based on these requirements uh we
decided to use data studio
data studio is a data visualization and
reporting
tool that's available freely from google
marketing platform
and it works very well with bigquery it
has a native connector to bigquery
if you're using bigquery data in data
studio you can use the bi engine to take
advantage of its fast in-memory uh
calculations and
get very speedy results so when
as the team was looking into this
solution
we realized that there were several
alternatives available
first was using the native connector to
create a single dashboard with viewers
credentials
what vious credentials mean is that when
someone would view the dashboard
their credentials would get passed
through data studio into the data source
which here would be bigquery and then
that
credentials would be used to enforce
what data they would get to see and here
would be using
[Music]
row level access either through data
studios
email based filtering or bigquery's
current user function but the limitation
here was that if we wanted to use either
of those two features we'd have to
merge all those datasets into one single
uh
table or source and then filter from
there which became a little bit
complicated because there were
over 1400 partners the second option was
to use again the native connector but
there would
create one template dashboard and then
copy over the dashboard
multiple times like each time one time
for each partner and then edit the
data source that it would point to the
right data set
that had its own challenges because it
would be possible to copy over the
dashboards
but if we wanted to make any future
changes or wanted to do maintenance
doing it over 1400 different dashboards
would become
near impossible so we opted for the
third solution which was the custom
connector
and we'll go into that more details
later but what the custom connector
would do is it would
make a customized solution involving
data studio and bigquery
it would meet all the repo reporting
requirements that i just mentioned
earlier
and this would require very minimum
level of development from the
team that was working on it the custom
connectors are built
on the community connector plat uh
platform for data
studio these are written in apps script
which are which is
uh google's cloud-based server-less
scripting engine and it's it takes very
low amount of effort to build
connectors using this framework anyone
can build a connector
you can connect to any external data
sources and pull in the data into data
studio
and it's also possible to share and
publish those connectors so that others
can use
if you are interested in learning more
about these connectors you can
check out the codelab we have at this
url
on the screen the comedy characters is
already a established program where
there are over 200 published connectors
available
and here at google we ourselves have
used this platform to
create several connectors to serve data
to
the public for example the chrome ux
connector
uses this connector platform to serve
chrome ux report data to users
so it was already a proven solution for
us however
one thing we have never tried with these
solutions was that
we didn't implement the your user base
view
in any of these connectors so what that
means is
in user base view multiple users will
look at the same dashboard but based on
their credentials who they are
it would fetch data from different data
sets which is a bit different from row
level access because we are accessing
completely different data sets and then
the dashboard would get populated with
data from those data sets
so this was something new that the team
was trying out uh with the community
character
approach and our end result would look
something similar to this that the
connector would get created and
using that connector we'd create a
dashboard a single dashboard link and
that would be sent to all the 400
different partners
when a partner opens their dashboard
link they will see their dashboard with
their own data
and they wouldn't have any flexibility
or option to switch over to see
a separate user dashboard so this is a
complete user experience we wanted to
have
user gets a link clicks on it they
immediately view their report
so to do this under the hood this is
what we had to implement
so once the user clicks on the dashboard
link it opens up the data studio
dashboard
and the data studio data studio will
then execute
the connector with viewers credentials
the first time they use any user opens
this dashboard they will have to go
through an authorization flow where they
authorized it uh this connector to run
on their behalf
but this is done only for the first time
they use it
for all subsequent times the dashboard
will open up automatically
so data studio executes the connector
script and the connector script then
takes the user's friendships and figures
out all right this is the email for the
this user who's viewing the dashboard
and then it makes a call to the bigquery
rest api
to figure out which dash which data set
should
uh this user be viewing so we had a
mapping table that mapped each user's
email address
with a specific list of data sets so
this rest api call enabled us
to query into bigquery and get the
result back where
bigquery would say all right this email
address x has
access to data set y so once this
information was
back in the connector we then construct
a new
query and this query string would
contain basically this
data set id that we just fetched so it
would say something like
select asterisk from data set y but we
would not send this query off to
bigquery directly what we would do is
that
then the connector would use the
bigquery uh the data studio advanced
services to make the query directly into
bigquery
so let's look a bit deeper into that
what that means
uh to communicate between data studio
and bigquery the native connector
directly works but when we're
working with a community character the
data will usually
have to pass through apps script and it
will have to be transformed and
processed
in abstract which adds a bit of
overhead in calculation and latency
using
advanced services for data studio what
we can do is rather than
passing the data through apps script we
can just pass the query itself to data
studio
and the data studio will make pass that
query to bigquery directly and fetch the
data
from bigquery using a native connection
the data does not pass through
apps script in any way so it results in
a much faster interaction
all the filters are automatically pushed
down and then the users also get a much
better
faster dashboard experience so finally
data studio passes that query into
bigquery which is the final query for
the dashboard which contains only the
data set
that this user is uh has access to c
and finally the results are back sent
back to data studio and
the history renders that data in
dashboard and the viewer finally can see
their dashboard with their own data so
since in the return query results step
only the users data set is passed there
is no way for
a different user to see that data set or
for this user to see data from a
different data set
so what's what does the end result look
like this is the whole process but when
the user finally opens the dashboard
they get a view that looks something
like this this is the view that all the
users
all the 1400 different partners see when
they open the dashboard they get a
dashboard like this
uh at the top there are filters they can
change the filters they can interact
with it and this dashboard will
indirectly present the data
for whatever filters or selections
they're making
each partner would see only their view
and not
they won't see anything else and based
on this dashboard
the team made some further improvements
where they added for their pages
they also added some monitoring where um
they could monitor
how the dashboard was being used through
strike stack driver
which partners were using it uh which
partners were uh
incurring additional uh data costs it's
also possible to set up
uh data limits by partner so
it's a future potential work is where we
could potentially take this
solution and then build in limits where
each partner would get a
say a certain amount of limit if they
hit that limit every month then
the dashboard won't become visible
another potential solution that can be
implemented on top of this is
using google analytics for data studio
it can be measured how the users are
interacting with the dashboard which
pages are they looking at
which pages where are they spending the
most time on
and then make the dashboard much better
and faster and more usable
for users that way if anyone wants to
build a similar
solution using data studio advanced
services and bigquery
uh this link with these links would be
helpful the first link
basically provides a step-by-step guide
on how to build a connector
similar to this and the second link
contains a code example of a similar
connector
you can just take the code example and
customize it to your own needs
so what finally happened after this
project this project was launched in
october 2019
after launch there were numerous
positive news stories over 200 new
stories were published on
digital trends and venture beats right
now over 6 000 users from more than 1400
partners
across the world are using this
dashboard every day
and as michael mentioned earlier uh the
connector that he created and the
dashboard the team
came up with it's working basically in a
no ops fashion
even with such high amount of usage and
there are over 30 000 accesses of the
datastore dashboard
and more than 800 000 queries have been
made in bigquery by all these partners
now waze uh this was a major
collaboration between waze and google
cloud
and waste plans to continue to promote
the data tools and build education
materials to
aid traffic planning across the world
and that brings us to the end of our
presentation
thank you